you
hi everyone it's Jerry let's have a look
at a game that was played on March 10th
1957 this was played in New York at the
Manhattan Chess Club
Game two of 2 from this mini exhibition
match between 14-year old Bobby Fischer
playing on the white end and Max Irving
this game was unknown for quite some
time unpublished for over 50 years and
it wasn't until Frank Brady came around
and shared this game with us
Frank Brady is the author of the book
endgame which is a biography of Bobby
Fischer and in his research for the book
he found Fischer's score she for this
game so we have him to thank for sharing
this game with us so let's dive in and
see how it develops we have on board a
Roy Lopez and to be a bit more exact
we're working with an open system Knight
takes e4 closed would be Bishop e7 where
the files go unchanged but here we're
now working with a half opened efile and
white wants to open it up some more
very sensible white king is safe blacks
king is still in the center b5 Bishop b3
and black is not getting greedy here
capturing on d4 you could be sure the
knight and the King will come under some
heavy fire fast so some emphasis on
development d5 white now regains the
pawn and something more is happening
with this last capture the structures
have changed White has a four to three
majority on the Kings side and the same
story for black on the Queen side from
here some defense of d5 it was under
fire
white opens a square for the bishop it
will not be hunted and after Bishop e7
white challenges the strongest black
piece the one that's in White's house
from here black castles moved ten now
one of the sharper continuations instead
of castles is Knights e5 and after
Bishop see to d4 things get really sharp
with this sequence but we go down a much
more positional path in this game
castles Queen e2 insisting that this
Knight leave it does at this moment
Knight c5 and we do not have Bishop c2
because once more d4 would hit and it
would be that much more effective that
much more threatening let's say because
d3 would also be a threat with the fork
now that the queen is on e - instead of
the home square so what does Fischer do
he makes sure d4 is not a move at all
Knight deform at the same time this is
clearing the way for White's majority
the F pawn is now free to move
ideally white would love to be able to
establish an e5 f5 pawn duo okay first
things first Knight takes bishop white
simply recaptures with the second-ranked
night at this stage will caught my
attention at this moment is can't white
take the knight on c6 with the fork and
win a piece this is not the case this
would would not be the case because
black would have an in-between move
taking the bishop and then the knight is
on the queen so we have a simple
recapture on b3 the bishops eyes are
opened up and on this move thirteen
Queen to d7 defending the knight
something that's especially important to
know I already drew some attention to
the majorities if you don't already
describe majorities as healthy or
unhealthy it'd probably be a good idea
to start doing that because black can
very easily find himself with an
unhealthy majority if not careful so for
example if you're playing as black now
and capturing the night light would
recapture with upon and black would now
be working with an unhealthy structure
black is never would never be able to
successfully get in the move c5 Knight
is there pawn is there that Bishop will
be there rook will be there forget about
it this is a half dead pawn okay black
understands this and says no way I'm not
giving you a great grip over the c5
square Queen d7 Knights are exchanged
and now Bishop e3 focusing on the c5
square black next to me if white can
maintain control over the c5 Square even
if with a piece that would mean the
majority is unhealthy for black so
there's something you really need to be
aware of this position can turn into a
strong night versus a bad Bishop in a
blink not saying this is the greatest
you know dummy move to be sharing with
you but suppose the Queen goes here on
blacks next move this would be a
wonderful opportunity for white to do
what force a dark square Bishop exchange
and establish a knight on c5 it's going
nowhere Queen could defend pawn can
defend this is one of those positions
you would see in a book titled aa or in
a in a chapter titled superior minor
piece or good night versus bad Bishop
something to steer clear of playing as
black must avoid that at all costs in
the game what do we have Queen c4
Fischer ducks
no Queen exchange for team black see
five hits so there's a bit of a timing
issue with blacks last move given one
more move black will be there in time to
secure c5 but Fischer now comes up with
a five move sequence that in the end
nets upon if you'd like to pause the
video and work out how exactly this is
done feel free to do that okay here we
go the move played in the game Knight a5
not too many options with the black
Queen Queen h4 and now knight c6 so the
threat here is to deflect the Queen away
from defending the bishop and just pick
up the bishop so black adds some defense
with the reliable piece the rook Fischer
gives the Queen a kick
what white wants to do is take the
bishop and not have the Queen recapture
and defend c5 so g3 only now take the
bishop and then take on c5 at the end of
it what do we have
Fisher's up upon but needs to be careful
because we have an opposite color
bishops position and with the move g3
guess what color squares have been
weakened light squares to be very
careful now
the bishop slipping in here Queen there
before you know it game over on g2 first
things first
rook is under fire counterpunch and
black just drops back to a nice secure
square you could go to d6 but I imagine
part of the arethe part of the reasoning
that goes into the move Bishop d4 is to
cut out any possibility for rook c4 in
the rook you know kind of drifting
quickly towards the Kings side not sure
what great square it would have but you
certainly rule that out this idea of
pivoting on c4 and having those
possibilities towards the Kings side
okay after Bishop d4 what do we have
Bishop g4 in the game I questioned at
this stage isn't this a wonderful
opportunity for black to play Bishop
dthe Bishop h3 and then Queen f3 I mean
what would you do if the bishop goes to
h3 there's only one good defensive move
here for white if you'd like to pause
the video see if you can figure it out
okay if Bishop h3 instead of the move
Bishop g4 in the game the best move here
is Queen d1 addressing this threat
making a rook move checkmate in two
the idea here the best move is queen d1
offering a queen exchange Queen takes
Queen you would take with the rook and
get out of the bishop swag and if the
Queen moves now we can move the rook
without fear of Queen f3 regarding that
square anyhow in the game Bishop g4
looking to get in at a different angle
Bishop f3 Queen h3 one way or the other
Queen Bishop on these two squares Queen
g2 for me what does Fischer do f4 so
this is allowing some lateral defense of
the G to square even if black has the
pieces here somehow the the major pieces
can guard g2 now that the pawn is on f4
from here rook c6 looking for this stuff
Queen is there though to defend what
does Fischer do opens it up on the other
side of the board Queen side this rook
is unprotected black is still without a
flight square B takes a rook takes rook
h6 this is defended Queen is there the
Queen you can rely upon as defense for
h2 can't be distracted Queen f2 in the
game there is a better continuation
white maintains a small plus and can
really build on it with move 26 there is
a better move besides Queen f2 computer
likes Bishop f3 questioning the rooks
position on h6 threat here is f5 and
white is close to gaining some control
over these very weakened light squares
what am I talking about exactly just as
a as an example if Bishop e3 and let's
say rook here f5 the rook is hit
then Brooke here we at least as white
start to control some light squares f5
this earlier mentioned duo is in and now
black has to worry about e6 or f6 there
would be absolutely no attack for black
if y can establish this position
happens in the game queen f2 Bishop f5
light doubles on the a file and rook to
c8 this pawn on e6 is poison it's
attacked twice defended once but if you
try and pick up the pond that would mean
that would mean what it would mean
White's back rank is vulnerable so as an
example if white takes like this in the
end the black queen is going to have
some fun combined with the bishop queen
d1 if the King steps up there's checks
and maybe even a checkmate and if the
Queen blocks we could take the Queen and
win the rook a6 is poison so we have
rook b4 preparing to exchange rooks b6
is the idea we have that and Queen g4 is
doing what exactly we see soon enough
the H pawn is now ready to roll
multi-purpose move here flight square
and a battering ram the H file is soon
to be peeled open white still up upon
but black is in the driver's seat here
even even though the engines at this
stage say you know white is a tiny bit
better this is a position where you
would kind of prefer to play as black
you know look at the activity
look at the squares the black pieces are
observing in White's house can't say the
same for the white side white has the
more vulnerable King that's the bigger
factor in this position King safety is
much more important than this material
imbalance this material plus that white
has so what follows rook f1 Bishop d3
the other rook is ready to make use of
that h6 square and it's going to be that
much more effective
especially combined with of course you
avoid the Queen exchange combined with
this h-file being opened up a rook on h6
now there's going to be some big trouble
for teamwipe boy tries to run with the
king
H files now opened up Black has managed
to activate all pieces Fisher is on his
back foot for sure very easy to go wrong
white goes wrong with this next move
computer suggests c4 try to undermine
the strong post of the Bishop c4 is not
played King d2 bishop b1 all sorts of
stuff to worry about Queen c2 rook to
one of these two moves rogue h2 actually
is a move because Queen c2 and there's a
skewer very difficult to defend this one
rook h1 in the game move 40 and after
move 41 rook to f1 this is a position
where black is better black is actually
winning black can at this point play
rook h2 and if the rook is captured we
have Queen c2 and then the Queen would
be one and if let's say rook f2 there's
a check another check and this Queen
gets really active I mean you could just
see that this Bishop is just a tall pawn
and all the black pieces are surrounding
the White King g3 is soon to fall and
well something like this black can
already do fancy stuff like sacking a
bishop checkmate
next move multiple ways to certainly put
pressure on white in this position
however after the move rook f1 according
to Frank Brady
what happened next Herve offered a draw
and Fisher
thought about it for a while and
reluctantly accepted which is I don't
know it it's definitely very very
interesting and to this game because
clearly Herve knew he was either winning
better he can press this position in so
many different ways the material is not
a factor here black is definitely for
choice maybe a bit of a courtesy draw
offer why exactly was Fischer may be
reluctant to accept the draw well on one
hand he knows there's no winning chances
here and the best he could do as a draw
but at the same time accepting a draw
would mean he loses them any match you
know he he really wants to win that kind
of thought and there's no I guess
Fischer had no sense of well there was
no satisfaction let's say with drawing
the fifth world champion he really
wanted to win and he had his chances in
this game I mean in the opening the
middle game he was in the driver's seat
and it was only towards the very end
that it really started to slip away and
Irv a had this better or really winning
position in the end after this 41st move
anyhow feel free to share your thoughts
on this interesting game it is to me at
least a very interesting game feel free
as usual to leave any comments in the
comment section below I hope you enjoyed
it and maybe even took a thing or two
away that's all for now take care bye
you